um jamal can you describe the feeling of
making nba history coming back for the
second time
and what it was like when you sort of
started to sense
uh that you guys were in control of this
game we sent so early
um and we dropped game three uh
you know we just came up the range we we
knew that we had them against the wall
and they weren't shooting well and we
just knew uh we got the looks we won the
first half they didn't drop
and we just made him the second um you
know we just can continue to play
through it like we always have the
series and in this playoffs and
um paid off you know so it's fun to you
know silence everybody that's talking
about us
talking negative about us and uh you
know we're gonna keep moving on from
here
all right next we'll go to kendra
andrews kendra go ahead
hey jamal in you and nicola's post game
interview with rachel
out on the court nicola was saying how
he's going to remember this team and
this is a special group
even before you know coming to the
bubble and what you guys have
accomplished in these two playoff
series so far what just makes this group
so special what will you remember most
about all these players you've been
playing with for now about
four years uh we built it from the
ground up
um somebody asked me who was the who's
the second highest
draft pick on our team i have to think
about it
and uh it was noah i think
it was noah than mike and you know we
rebuilt this team from the ground up and
we've been
you know through the trenches and just
the hard work's paying off
that's all i can say um everybody counts
us out
and it's just fun it's just fun to
silence everybody we love it and that's
what makes it so special when we play
with no pressure when we go out and just
play free and trust each other and
it shows in our playing shows and energy
and how we talk and how we celebrate and
and what we're doing how we react and
how we take action and uh
this was just another series where we
got that done
all right next we'll go to tj mcbride tj
go ahead
hey jamal congrats on the huge win i was
curious if there was any kind of
evolution throughout this playoff period
for you and the team that maybe you guys
grew in any particular way or if this is
exactly who you guys have been
and you're just showing everybody
exactly who you guys are
we've been we've been showing it we've
been showing it i don't know how to also
say we've been showing it and
you got shaq you got charles you got i
think zach loves his name i don't even
know
um steven a all y'all better start
giving this team some damn respect
because we put in the work and we got a
resilient team and
you know we should we should have been
down 3-1 but
you know to come back from 3-1 against
the clippers um it was a big achievement
so
uh it's fun just to you know change that
narrative yeah y'all can finally
start changing the narrative and uh
looking less in a better light
all right next we'll go to dave
mcminiman dave go ahead
hey jamal congrats on the win uh the the
nugget excuse me the the clippers were
the vegas favorites
coming into the year the reigning finals
mvp
um a championship head coach how did you
guys view them as an opponent
and um you know obviously
you were able to overcome a 3-1 deficit
so what gave you guys
the belief to have success against that
team in particular
you know a lot of people talk about us
but we just improved our argument
that's all i gotta say that's how we
feel
all right next we'll go to mark kizla
mark go ahead
hey jamal um joker what do you love most
about him
and is he kind of like your big brother
or your big basketball brother is that
cone too far man tell me
now we're hand to hand um
maybe it's because we both play overseas
or something like that i don't know
but uh though we play off each other and
find everybody
i think it's amazing um he's just so
dominant in the post and
you know 101 he's gonna score if you
double he's gonna pass and uh you know
just
he's incredible he plays with such a joy
uh free-flowing game
without any pressure even if he does
something dumb or has 20 turnovers
he still plays free and plays within
himself so now it's fun to see him go
out there and
uh not i wouldn't say take the game
lightly but um
look at it in the light where he knows
what he put into this game and where
he's gotten him and you know he just
tries to go out there and show it with
how he plays and how he how he reacts
with us and he's been amazing he's been
incredible and you just saw
another performance from him tonight
all right next we'll go to katie wendy
katie go ahead
hey maul coach talked about the
evolution of this group went back to the
game 82 in minnesota that you guys
missed the playoffs with last year
you're in this same spot
you don't win that game at home and now
you make it over that hump
what when you think about that what has
that evolution been like for you
and how did this team grow to a point
where you guys are now in the western
conference finals
we know what we got and uh well we're
all clicking we're all when we're making
shots like that and playing defense
together
now we're our top four team top three
team in the league
and we're trying to prove to be the
number one and we gotta go into lakers
and
uh fight that series but you know we
we've been doing this i don't know how
many times you know we gotta prove it
over you know we've been doing this and
we have the time to do it
and uh we're going to get better mbj's
mbj is not even starting yet no will's
not even here
so like i said we got a squad and we
just believe each other and we know we
can go there and win it
right next we'll go to jeff zilgit jeff
go ahead
games five six and seven where you saw
it in their eyes
that they do that you guys were taking
over the game
no i think we saw in game three i think
when we dropped that game it was
self-inflicted
i think they realized how good we were
um
you know when you play somebody over and
over and over again um we start to
figure them out and start to figure out
what works and how they play and
um you know we just know we're younger
we got we got a lot of legs and
uh we got a lot of energy and we brought
it and uh
you know they didn't match that but they
got they got who they got they got
talented squad and they got docked too
um they got cisco about to be head
coaches so
we know what they have i think we just
we just
outworked them a little bit with their
young legs and brought a little more
energy than they did
all right next we'll go to nick cosmeter
nick go ahead
yeah jamal it's the nature of the league
that sometimes you don't get to play the
league and
you know and grow five you know four
five six years with with the same coach
how much is the relationship you guys
have built with with michael malone and
the growth you've had together how much
does that all play a part into this or
how big of a part huge part
huge part um
you know it's a lot a lot of is about
trust
you know sometimes no coach will call
plays call plays
let's do this that now he's asking what
do you want to do now he's asking joker
what do you see
you know what you guys want to explain
so you know the back and forth dialogue
is big to us when we get to talk it out
and and go back and forth a little bit
and that's earned
and uh coach has given us a lot of more
trust to run the offense and as long as
we play defense
we can do whatever we want on offense
don't move the ball and get good shots
and
play for each other that's all he wants
and uh he's he's
defensively he's great you know not just
him but coach west too
um coming up with all these schemes and
and how we play stuff and
um how we handle you know kawhi paul
george
uh and the rest of the guys you know so
uh it's all about trust and we've just
been growing like you said
my fourth year here um we got a lot more
to a lot more the game
all right we have time for one more
question here and we'll end with
harrison wind harrison go ahead
hey jamal i know we've talked a lot
about physicality this series and
way back in february you guys lost these
guys uh
by a bunch and i know met after the game
and said what needs to change
what do you remember about that
post-game meeting back in february and
what do you have to say about just the
second half effort and how you guys just
imposed your will in the fourth tonight
i can you could also say we lost to
cleveland um we lost atlanta
and we beat we beat the good team so i
mean the regular season you know
playoffs is where you
playoffs for the playoffs um this is
where it matters and uh
you know we brought the physicality and
you know we made it just need to make
regular season anything happen the
regular season um
you know so i don't really know what to
how to you know answer that one